arguably the most important part of a
business document is its introduction it
is so important to from the very
beginning capture the interest of your
readers also of your viewers if you're
presenting something this is exactly
what we're going to talk about today in
this video my name is heinrich welcome
to my channel firm learning this is the
place where i want to help you become
successful in the first years of your
career today i want to introduce you to
a framework an introduction framework
that is taught in almost every
on-boarding program of any of the large
consulting firms like mckinsey bcg or
bain i trust this will be important
because it's just so versatile you can
use it for almost every business
document that you use the first that i
want you to understand is that good
business writing is not something that
either comes or does not come to you
like many other things it's a skill that
needs to be practiced and can be learned
and for sure in consulting onboarding
programs at the large strategy
consulting firms this always played a
big role and an important part of that
is the introduction because compared to
people reading a book clearly no one
will ever be as excited to read your
business document as the person might be
excited just to read their favorite book
their favorite novel they're just filled
with action excitement or whatever other
topic they're really interested in so as
a good business writer with your
introduction you want to create at least
a little bit of this excitement of this
interest of your reader in your document
so as most good books your introduction
should have a beginning a middle part
and an ending and there is one framework
which is very commonly used and taught
in consulting firms which i believe is
at the core of almost all good
introductions and this framework is the
framework of situation complication
solution so let's now go over these
three fundamental components of
introduction and let's start with the
situation
so the situation is the start of
introduction where you briefly describe
how the situation currently looks like
so here you're looking for a couple of
sentences where you know that other
people we agree to them so you know that
the people reading your document will
say yes this is exactly the situation
that we're currently facing this is what
the state is called what this currently
looks like so you don't want to go with
something controversial but rather
something where you know that you have
the buy-in of everyone reading this just
to make sure that this is captivating
and you will have common grounds with
all your audience of course and this is
then true for the other parts as well
how detailed this is going to be will
depend on the overall context of your
document so if your total document your
total memo is only two or three pages
long probably this whole introduction
will only be one or two paragraphs
whereas if your document is 50 pages 100
pages so even longer than likely this
introductory part can also be one or two
pages or so or even longer what's
important for these first sentences of
your situation part is that what you
write is captivating so it leaves the
reader being interested in what you're
saying and wanting to understand further
how the situation will evolve what you
will have to say about the situation so
this is this first part of the
introduction so let me make a couple of
examples for what sentences you could
write before the situation here looking
at another screen to read them so for
instance you could write something like
the profit margin of our company has
been steadily declining over the last
five years
that seems interesting so what do we do
about this right this is then the next
question how this will be making
hopefully of interest to your readers or
next the public health crisis our world
is currently facing created a
significant impact on our everyday life
so again an uncontroversial statement
that somehow leaves me asking okay like
what do we do how does this continue our
next
youtube channels have a great capacity
to teach educational material
so i hope we all agree with that but
once again
what does this mean what is the
implication of that right so this is
exactly the effect that you want to
create start with something
uncontroversial and then build based on
that so before we now continue let me
introduce you to the sponsor of this
week's video data camp data camp is an
online learning platform where you can
improve your data analysis skills you
know that this is something i talk about
all the time this is really a crucial
part of your skill set if you want to
succeed in any consulting role and i
trust in many roads in industry and for
sure in banking as well with datacam
there are no previous data skills needed
to get started you can learn from things
as basic as xl101 to more advanced
technical things like for instance
database manipulation and sql so for
sure if the things that i show you here
in this video are over your head you
really have no idea what this is all
about there are some also very
introductory courses on excel in data
camp which i trust can help you they
have over 300 courses with interactive
learning and you can also learn on the
go with the mobile app that they have
personally i very much liked the
introduction to sql cores which already
helped me several times on my own
projects when i needed to interact with
databases so give it a try and i trust
that working with data camp indeed can
fast track your data analysis skills and
these for sure are so crucial in any
consulting role but also many other
related roles as well so if this speak
to your interest and you would like to
try out datacam then invest in yourself
check out datacam via the link in the
video description and you will get
access to the first chapter of every
single course for free let's continue
with part two of your introduction and
this is the complication part so these
should be then the sentences that
directly follow the situation part and
here you know introducing some elements
which make the whole situation a bit
more complex a bit more complicated
maybe there's an additional problem that
is part of the situation that you are
describing so something that maybe now
is indeed a little bit more
controversial so here maybe there are
some people in the room or some people
reading this that would not necessarily
agree or maybe this is just a little bit
more controversial but this is then fine
for the second part one thing that's
important to understand is that the
complication does not necessarily need
to be a problem it can also just indeed
be just an additional factor that acts
to the complexity an additional factor
that just makes the whole situation more
interesting more worthwhile of our
attention things like that can be great
complications as well now to make it a
bit easier for you to understand what a
strong complication is let me talk about
this book the pyramid principle this is
a book that already recommended to you
in some of the prior videos and in the
video today i'm also boring on a couple
of concepts that i explained in this
book and indeed the situation
complication solution framework is also
a framework that is picked up in here
and explained and here there are a
couple of examples what great
complications could be let me just read
a couple of them for you to make it
clear so good complication could be
something went wrong
so you introduce the situation and now
you are adding an additional point that
shows how something went wrong
or another one could be something could
go wrong so what would there be right
like what are you describing something
could go wrong in the situation that
you're currently facing
something changed or something could
change so maybe we all agree that
currently the situation looks like this
but maybe this is not how it will look
like forever or here's what you might
expect to find in it so what exactly is
in the situation what is going on
or here's someone with a different point
of view maybe we all agree that this is
how the situation currently looks like
but other people hold these other views
this is how other people see it or
in this situation we have three
alternatives so this is currently what
we are facing and this is now what we
could do about it so i hope you
understand the complication does not
necessarily need to be a problem but
just something that adds to the
situation makes it a little bit more
spicy more worthwhile of our attention
then the last part of the complication
should always be a question
a question that builds on the
complication and is then usually the
most logical question to ask so for
instance if then you are introducing in
the complication the point that someone
else might have a different view on
something then the question is so what
is this view or if we have now three
potential solutions to address an issue
what are these solutions what could we
do or if the situation is changing how
is it changing right so always asking
this logical next question that also the
reader will ask him or herself because
this is of course what captivates the
interest what these people want to know
and now it starts to become a little bit
like an interesting book where you just
want to know how it continues right how
this goes on this is exactly i want to
captivate the interest of the people now
let's continue with the solution aspect
of this introduction so the last aspect
of it and of course the solution should
provide a nice and concise answer to the
question that you posed in the
complication segment what's here also
important to understand is that similar
with the complication the solution does
not necessarily need to be a solution to
a specific problem just call it like
that just to make it a bit more like
actionable but it can also be understood
just as a key message a key insight that
you want to share so based on the
questions that we just asked ourselves
earlier you provide a good and clear
answer the solution the key message that
you want to share
and which is not the starting point for
the top-down communication message that
you will have not to follow the starting
point to the main document that you are
now outlining what's important about the
solution section also to provide a
proper introduction then to the main
part of the document is then in the end
to also outline the main structure of
the document so talk to the reader about
what they can now expect if they
continue reading so how have you
structured it how have you now detailed
the solution in the main part of your
document what's important on this though
is also discussed in many of my slide
writing videos you once again if you're
interested more on this content i will
link the slide writing playlist of my
channel above it's important that you do
not talk about the structure but rather
the ideas the contents right so avoid
saying now in the solution in the end
that now the document for instance will
also outline enable enablers of your
ideas but instead in half a sentence
right what the most important enabler
for your solution is so to make this now
easier to understand let me just provide
you with a simple example of how such a
total introduction could look like now
based on a document that is maybe rather
short and not that long and this
introduction goes as follows let me just
read it out to you
the profit margins of our company have
been steadily declining over the last
five years
this is the situation as we've already
seen in us earlier
next this is not the complication
in addition
new competitors have entered our home
market this year putting additional
pressure on our market share
what can we do to address this issue
so you know you're introducing an
additional factor that makes it even
more challenging maybe it's a bit more
controversial also but scholar provides
why act now it provides an answer to the
question why now something needs to
happen why this whole issue is really
worthwhile of our attention right now
and indeed now you could continue in
saying this report outlines how a shift
from product selling to solution selling
could defend our market share and
increase our profitability we will
highlight what processes and
capabilities we need to make this happen
and how the implementation roadmap looks
like so here now in the solution segment
of the introduction you're first saying
what your hypothesis is of how this
could be addressed namely the shift from
product selling to solution selling and
now you also provide a brief outline of
what is that will follow namely what the
key segments are but rather in the terms
of ideas than those structure elements
namely processes and capabilities which
you feel like are a very important part
of that but also an implementation
roadmap and how this will look like how
this will happen so situation
complication solution it is just my
humble experience that if you set up
your introductions in this way you will
in most cases succeed in providing quite
an effective and also interest capturing
introduction to your business documents
i can just encourage you to try this out
in the next document that you write and
of course let me know how this worked
out for you what i can only tell you is
that this is just a framework that is
applied excessively in consulting what
do you think about using the situation
complication solution framework for your
introductions does this make sense to
have other things that you know that you
would love to share with the from
learning community please let me know in
the comments and as always if you took
any value out of this video at all
please hit the like button for the
youtube algorithm and also subscribe to
this channel to stay up to date on all
my content i once again want to thank
datacam for sponsoring this video and
thereby contributing to the firm
learning community and of course also
big thanks to all the members of firm
learning my name is heinrich i'm
releasing new videos every single
saturday so see you soon next week until
then all the best to all of you and bye
bye